what's going on guys this is rob and my
voice is still recovering from san diego
comic-con i literally destroyed my voice
while i was there because i was in hall
h and it was amazing and i was at
ballroom 20 when they announced all the
marvel animation stuff so excited for
x-men 97.
god i'm so hyped it was just it was one
hell of a weekend we are gonna have
content coming up or coming out from
over the time that we were in san diego
but what i want to talk about in this
video is i want to talk about black
panther right i want to talk about who
the new black panther is going to be and
honestly there's there's all these
different ideas that are circulating
around out there right if they weren't
going to go in the direction of riri
williams being um iron heart which is to
say like the whole modified iron man
suit that she reverse engineered on her
own i would say she would be a great
person to take over the mantle of black
panther the problem is they'd kind of be
bringing her out of nowhere and i think
it makes more sense to go with existing
like established characters from the
black panther mythos from the first film
to make that person a new black panther
as opposed to just snatching up ruby
williams modifying her story throwing a
panther suit on her and calling it a day
and i and and to be honest with you guys
that that would probably piss off a
bunch of fans right and and here's the
thing right this is something i do want
to talk about here for a second
i firmly believe black panther 2 is
going to be the best marvel cinematic
universe movie to date in terms of
grossing the most money i don't really
know but in terms of it being the best
movie they've made i think it will
honestly i think it's going to make a
ton of money i think it'll either rival
in-game or potentially pass it for no
other reason than the fact that people
are going to want to know what does this
movie look like now that chadwick
boseman has passed on right like what
does the film look like now right it's
like when paul walker died and that fast
and the furious movie came out the one
that didn't have him and it made like a
billion dollars because everybody wanted
to go see it because it's like what does
this movie look like with paul walker
not in it so um i think that's the same
thing that's going to happen with black
panther too you can call a little bit
morbid if you want to but that's just
the nature of people right we're
inherently curious
and so the the reason why i think the
movie is going to be so well done is
because disney can't afford to screw it
up if marvel studios and disney come out
with a black panther 2 film post
chadwick boseman and they mishandle even
one aspect of that film people are never
going to let them live it down and and
people are going to say well you're
you're you know ruining the legacy of
charlotte boston or whatever logic they
choose to be upset about it they're
going to hold on to that forever and and
it'll it'll literally turn into a pr pr
nightmare while i wouldn't say that
screwing that movie up would like kill
the mcu it would severely tarnish its
reputation in the eyes of fans because
whether you want to believe it or not
the marvel cinematic universe is a
purely fan driven industry the instant
fans stop being interested in mcu movies
that's the moment they die because fans
are what keep it propped up right the
excitement of the films and going to see
the films loving the films all that kind
of stuff that's why they do so much fan
service in those movies because it's
literally built on the the enjoyment of
fans and so that's why i think the movie
is going to be made so well because they
can't afford to screw it up having said
that let's talk about who the new black
panther is going to be right let's let's
talk about this for a second so there
are like two huge options
that are out there right the first one
obviously is shuri and if they want to
borrow from the comics shuri makes the
most sense those of you guys who don't
know what that means in marvel comics
they had a really really cool story
called doom war and this is i think
going to be to a degree elements of
do-more i think that's going to be a
plot of black panther too that what i
think is going to happen here is that i
don't know if dr doom is going to have a
hand in it it'd be really cool if he did
it'd be a great way to introduce his
character and to just make him a
character that right off the bat you
already hate but you'll love to hate
right that's the great thing about
doctor doom like doctor doom is that
he's the he's the guy like he's just
he's such an amazing character but in
doom war what ended up happening is
there came a point where doctor doom
realized or had already known for a
while but decided to make his move that
wakandan vibranium had the ability to
amplify magical energy and in order to
grant himself more power what he did is
he orchestrated what was in effect a
nationalist uprising in wakanda
and that basically led to the ousting of
t'challa and his wife's storm and then
shuri of course when t'challa was
injured shuri became the new black
panther and then just kind of stayed
there really as more of a figurehead in
wakanda more than anything else because
the nationalists were the ones who were
running the show and that while this
whole coup would happen doctor doom had
snuck into wakanda basically presented
himself to the panther goddess bast plot
his case about how using all this power
he would make the world better and he
actually would have and then in turn
bass let him take all the vibranium from
wakanda back to latviria which he used
to make himself god the way that story
ended is that in order to defeat doctor
doom that basically his source of power
had to be eliminated i.e wakandan
vibranium and so t'challa rendered all
wakandan vibranium across the world
inert it was just a useless chunk of
rock it lost its value the value like
plummeted to zero the way wakanda stayed
rich is they bought up a whole bunch of
national debt and so countries are
basically going to pay them forever so
that's how they stayed rich but the fact
remains here that i think that what's
going to happen in black panther 2 as
the overarching plot is that with
chadwick boseman passing i wouldn't be
surprised if there was some kind of uh
of grassroots uprising in wakanda
especially if they come along and they
say like sure he's the new black panther
or uh you know maybe like uh like naki
is a new black panther something like
that somebody that the people refuse to
recognize as being the rightful heir to
the throne of t'challa and then in turn
some nationalist group takes hold and
tries to oust him right it was that's
one of the best things about doom war is
it was literally a wakandan nationalist
uprising people who were like this whole
idea of wakanda being more open to the
world and all that kind of stuff that's
a problem we need to go back to the way
things used to be right and that was a
major focal point when it came to like
black panther the aftermath of uh
captain america and the winter soldier
that uh that that t'challa wanted to
open the doors of wakanda for the rest
of the world right he won he didn't want
to be closed off anymore so honestly the
stage is set perfectly for there to be
some kind of an uprising right where
people are just like no we need to
return ourselves back to our actual
roots right back to us as wakandans this
proud nation we don't need the outside
meddling with us we need to focus on our
heritage that kind of stuff and going
forward from there right so the stage is
kind of set for that so i wouldn't be
surprised if even if that's not the
overarching plot that is an element of
the plot i think it'd be a great way to
go for that story especially because it
would really highlight the significance
of chadwick boseman passing but but the
the first option here of course again is
shuri that was shuri having become black
panther in the comics as a result of
doom war and basically operating as
black panther going forward with
t'challa maintaining the name but being
more of like a ceremonial figure it just
makes good sense the biggest issue that
you have with this is that shuri is not
trained as a fighter she's a
technological person now sure maybe the
dora malachi could train her to become a
capable fighter but it really isn't
believable to look at shuri and to to
think over the span of however much time
has passed since chadwick boseman since
t'challa had basically died in the the
movie universe itself because disney's
confirmed that with black panther 2
coming out t'challa will have died in
the mcu it wouldn't really be believable
to say okay like maybe six months have
passed right they wouldn't let it go
like three years before they choose a
new black panther so it'd be kind of
hard to say okay in the span of six
months sure he became every bit the
fighter that t'challa was even though
he'd been training all his life so that
doesn't really make a whole lot of sense
having having said that what she lacks
in terms of like martial arts skill she
could make up for in technology so she
could still be an effective black
panther just not in the same way that
we're traditionally used to seeing with
t'challa so shuri is a viable option
here i think one of the more popular
options is nakia i think a lot of people
look at her and they think she's the
best person to do it and i think really
whether or not she would make a
compelling black panther not so far in
how she operates as a black panther but
in terms of like her motivations for
being black panther are really rooted in
how it is that t'challa died if he died
by way of violent means which is a very
it's a very risky road to take in the
mcu then certainly her character would
be rooted in revenge revenge against
whoever it was that ended up killing
t'challa right and i doubt it'd be one
of those things where she would approach
the mantle out of anger like i'm so
angry t'challa died i'm gonna take up
his mantle as black panther and we'll be
tied the poor soul that does anything i
don't like you know i don't really think
that would be the case having said that
she is capable right she is uh she she
is somebody that can certainly hold her
own and she's a fan favorite or she's a
fan favorite pick to play the role of of
uh of black panther what i want to do
here is given those two options i
actually want to sidestep for a second
and i want to go with two other options
that i think are easy to consider here
and i think are actually a couple a
couple better options than those two so
the first one is one that i think a lot
of people are familiar with and a lot of
people even speculated this at one point
in time which is imbaku he'd be a great
choice to be the new black panther
especially if you have him combining the
wakandan tribe and the jabari people
that would be cool right unify them
under one single leadership right one
single role or just kind of go forward
from there um so i think it'd be a great
choice he has the size he has like the
the physical prowess to do it the
difference between baku and t'challa is
that ambaku does not have the finesse
that that t'challa had t'challa's
movements were fluid right they were
very very just clear-cut he was able to
move in a way where one move led into
another very bruce lee-like in terms of
how he fought but again i think that's
holding on to the depiction of black
panther as we've seen him in these in
the ncu versus what what the black
panther character could become later on
and so my my real choice here if you're
if the marvel cinematic universe is
coming to me and they say okay rob like
ryan coogler hits me up you know when
they were working on the film and
chadwick mostly passed and they said
okay we need a new black panther rob who
would you pick i would pick a koi i
think she'd be the best person to be
black panther she's a fighter she was
fiercely loyal to the panther clan she
was fiercely loyal to the family line
she was the the best fighter in the dora
malachi she was a little reckless and
headstrong she was stubborn and she
usually always believed that she was
right but all the attributes she
demonstrated were the attributes of a
great leader she's respected by the by
the royal family and wakanda and
presumably the rest of the wakandan
people just because of the kind of
things she's done she's very capable and
so i think okoye is honestly the best
choice to be black panther just given
the various abilities that she has at
her disposal and how effective she would
be at black panther but again the bigger
question to ask here is that when it
comes down to it who would the fans be
the most receptive to and so that's my
question to you who do you want to see
take over the role of black panther in
the marvel cinematic universe let me
know down in the comments section but
thank you all for watching and i'll
catch you all later
peace